California,
the blow-me state, uh,
recently passed
a spate of new laws,
and boy, howdy,
are they enforceable.
For instance,
you are no longer allowed
to hold your cell phone
while driving.
Uh, that is really going
to cut into
my carpool lane masturbation,
but, hey...
-(laughter) -...the life
it saves may be your own.
Also, California Uber drivers
are no longer allowed
to be sex offenders or drunk.
Oh...
(laughter)
That's a good rule.
-Way to stay ahead of the curve.
-(laughter)
Comedians, as California goes,
so does the nation,
and we are a nation of laws.
What are some new laws
you'd like to see passed
in other states?
Ron Funches.
Uh, in Florida, it is now legal
to fight with your shirt off
and (bleep) with your shirt on.
-HARDWICK: All right.
-(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
(laughter)
Nothing wrong with
a Florida shirt-cocking.
There's nothing wrong with that.
Kyle Kinane.
Uh, in Massachusetts,
if you can make it through
a Dropkick Murphys concert
without starting a fistfight,
you can skip
a child support payment.
(laughter)
-(applause and cheering)
-HARDWICK: Oh. Finally.
(Funches giggling)
Mary Lynn.
Alaska, go ahead
and (bleep) a moose.
We know you're doing it anyway.